but let's crack into this one as i've
got an
absolutely ready to share some ladder
stories for you kiwis who don't follow
english premiership the name might not
ring a bell but for
all of you english premiership fans well
um
it still might not ring a bell to you
but i promise you that this guy is an
absolute lad and a very talented young
rugby player who is about to explode
onto the english premiership scene when
he gets a chance it is of course
young jacob snakeb atkins welcome snake
thanks for coming on
thanks for having me on tony um mate i'm
surprised you got time to
chat to me at the moment haven't you
just had number three i have indeed mate
but we've always got time for you
the talented oh that's true man that is
the snake
so what's happening over there anyway um
what's the situation with
covert and um the rugby
i i don't know if much of your listeners
in new zealand are following what's
going on in the uk but we are still very
very much
national lockdown um
it's a bit of a shambles mate um they've
they've
uh they've totally [ __ ] it up
um the cases are still high so it is
literally a case at the moment
of go in train go home don't leave your
house unless you go to the shops
i don't know what that was called for
you guys but it's tier tier
four or five here i don't remember but
you're still a little trained
yeah so professional sports still
allowed to go on um
so we're allowed to go in and train and
do a lot of stuff yeah and that's just
normal
you can be 15 or 15 there's no
restrictions around training or anything
like that
um masks in the gym
meetings outside um
training's all normal but you're not
allowed face to face contact so
actually in the last couple of weeks
they banned face-to-face celebrations
um yeah which is i was on the bench for
one of the games in the european cup and
one of the boys scores under the sticks
and i run over jump right and pretty
much kiss him in the face
a real screaming in his face back off uh
bloke goes down with coving two days
later
and i have to self-isolate and they're
sending out the footage like all right
this guy
uh it needs to go so they back they've
banned face-to-face celebrations
oh is it what um curtis rona's
celebration was yeah
did you see it yeah i think you can get
far i think you can get five teams can
get fined and stuff if
if uh players take the piss with it the
team does or the player
hopefully the team
but what about the um competition what's
that what's the setup there like how far
through of the season are you and
how the game's been going yeah mate so
the premierships
uh it's uh it's it's hard to keep track
of how many rounds we're actually in
because
there's been a couple of games that have
been cancelled due to code but basically
if any team gets any positive cases
their game is cancelled uh they have to
be contact traced to the team they
played last so potentially
their game could then get cancelled as
well um we
had two games we lost the kovid because
we had a few positive tests
um for two weeks um
most teams have had at least one either
they've had positive tests or the team
they're playing has had a positive test
so it is hard to keep track of actually
how many rounds we're through but i
think i think it's eight
but there's teams some teams have played
eight sometimes have played six
yeah but you guys have moved to
brentford stadium now so how's that been
yep yeah yeah but it's um it's real cool
i mean before we were at majeski which
was a great stadium but yeah kind of out
in the middle of nowhere
um the the new stadium in brentford is
you know it's a brand new stadium
uh state-of-the-art facility just
outside central london it's
oh it's gun made it's uh it's such a
nice facility we managed to get out
there
uh in pre-season to play like an
in-house e um
to get a feel for it which uh which is
so cool and then we haven't actually oh
no we've had fans in once
uh of all the games we played this
season we had fans in for the one week
that
uh the lockdown was eased here uh we
were allowed two thousand fans in and
it was it was brilliant it was really
really good the week after we were
told we weren't allowed fans anymore so
uh it's strange playing in a brand new
stadium but no one in it but
um i'm sure it'll be rocking when uh
when this thing gets sorted
yeah because your fans will be battling
with that because that's one thing i
definitely remember over there is how
passionate those london irish fans were
even when we're in the championship
far out we were getting massive turnouts
and everyone was still
like right behind the side i could only
imagine what they'll be like now
and then to have this restriction that
would just be absolutely killing them
yeah 100 percent like they must be there
must be the most loyal fans in
england you reckon like being through
multiple relegations and promotions
following us
up and down the country to grounds in
the middle of nowhere like
like you said i remember we every time
we'd go to pirates it stacked out like
four or five thousand fans would have
made an eight hour round trip or
whatever to
to come and watch us play in a game that
had no effect on whether we were going
to win the comp or not
um it's class so yeah it's it it's
it's a club that's really important to
lots of people and like you said i think
especially during lockdown at the moment
there'll be a lot of people that
are pretty gutted they can't be there
luckily
they've on bt sport they've started
showing all the games
so you can go on like the red button and
watch every single game
um so hopefully there won't be too many
fans that aren't actually able to see
the stuff but it's
yeah it'd be good to get them back soon
and your um
form i mean you still every time i look
at the team [ __ ] i'm always disappointed
not to see big jake getting a run
another sort of frustrating year for you
so far
in that respect is frustrating like you
say like it would be
it would be good to be involved more
um in terms of playing time but
it's it's a strange one for me at the
moment makes i feel really really
confident in my game
um when i have had my opportunities i
think i've gone well
i feel like i i know my game really well
and i'm really confident with
with my skills and my decision making
and stuff so it's kind of like on the
one hand i feel
really good about myself and about my
game and really confident
and on the other hand it's like well i'm
not playing that much you know it's a
bit frustrating yeah
um you don't know what it's like because
you're fast track outs but
like lots and lots of the people
listening will know what it's like when
you're not playing it
it can be a bit of a battle yeah you're
only 23 aren't you
yeah yeah yeah yeah 23. yeah so yeah i
definitely not cracked it by 23 so you
still got lots of time i can tell you
that i was not fast-tracked like you
think
thank god thank god but you are just
wait you are just pretty much waiting
for your opportunity aren't you to get
some regular game time and then
yeah let england see what a talented ten
they have
sitting on there sitting in this squad
yeah
like like clover actually ended up doing
pretty good for me last year because
um they had to end up doubling up some
weeks so you'd have like
saturday game wednesday game sunday
again yeah
so i got a few starts and stuff back
into last season which was good but
um yeah it'd be good to get a few more
soon and uh
talk me through the hair obviously that
was a big decision that was always on
your
um always on your mind from a young age
you had the
you were vulnerable to a bit of lasagna
at an early age and you've decided to
just
get rid of that threat and shave it all
off so how talk me through that decision
and how tough that was
well what do you think about my look at
the moment boss i'm going after
sort of styled on my my hero ben franks
she definitely looked like being frank
she pulled that off
um yeah i know the lasagna i mean you're
getting on now jimmy you're not catching
any lasagna or are you still all good
no i'm still you've got a cap on most
days a famous black cap so i don't know
if you've
i don't know if you actually got a bit
of lasagna no i'm all right with the
lasagna it's just the full
full-on graves for me which is the
danger which is basically why we're the
cat
all the time but yeah the lasagna is
always a dangerous spot with
when the sun's out i know it's not sunny
over there at the moment yeah
yeah mike homan another famous victim of
a
lasagna in the summer yeah for those
people who don't know what lasagna is
it's um
when you get burnt in the vulnerable
patches around where the receder starts
to form and
um some people get caught out pretty big
pretty heavily i
remember you get caught out a few times
but um if it starts
peeling or crusting it almost looks like
a little bit of lasagna in the top of
your head so
um that sort of caught on and i think
most people around the world refer to it
as
lasagna if they get some burnt up there
now so they will do now
um yeah it's funny you bring that up
though like it i've
i've had my head shaved for a couple
years now um we've got a good crew of
bald lads
irish now billy meeks over another
bulldog
holly hoskins as well yeah so there's
there's a bit of a good crew of us but
i remember back in the day like one day
i just came into training and
gordy reid like it was actually in the
middle of a 15-15 session that
whistle blew over and went into drill he
literally just walked past me as like
mate please just just come around mine
tonight i'll make you some dinner
what a chat shave your head it'll be the
best thing you ever do
and then i was like
all right i did went round he was living
with saya
flying her and um went around had dinner
with them
shaved my head and then never looked
back mate what do you reckon
no i like it i do think it was a good
decision i mean
you were just hanging on i think some
people hang on for too long but you've
made the call pretty early it must have
been what
22 when you decided then were yeah
21 yeah oh so young but oh no regrets
look at that
and do you think it's helped your form
at all hard to tell because you haven't
been playing but
um i've gotten stronger since
maybe that's because i've gotten older
but
maybe i don't know brexit stronger
there you go yeah loving the gym number
um
has it helped my game no no i'd like to
say
like maybe it may be seem a bit tougher
or whatever but anyone that's watched my
clips has not fallen for that
you need to take
i don't know god that might be the end
of my career if i start doing that gmg's
if i ever start taping my head give me a
ring and tell me suck it in
i know we used to joke about it but you
um do you think the coaches know how
young you are because
i mean i you always look a lot older
than you
like 21 hardly any hair left
do you think the coaches know that
you're only actually 23.
um well i mean uh irish the the turnover
of players mate has been so high
the only players that have been there
longer than me are blair cowan
and uh
holly hoskins at the same same time theo
theo brophy clues was signed the year
before me yeah
but other than that mate like i've been
there longer than most people and i'm
23. so it's actually a thing i do think
sometimes when i go in for a meeting
with decky i think about that
i can actually slip in that i'm not 29
year old 30 year old battle
here like just think just in case he
thinks i am
are you in the leadership groups and
stuff no no no no no
no no we've got uh there's like four
lads in our leadership group
oh yeah very select crew
in anyway let's go back to the start for
the young jacob
atkins when did you um when did the
snake first
wriggle out of his egg talk me through
that um
so i'm gonna outline this whole section
by saying my family are massive
code heads um my brother's a
professional player as well plays irish
he
signed the year after you left the thing
you never played it indeed i remember
you brother because moose still gives me
[ __ ] to this day
about him dominating me on a hit shield
one who won training
yes yes he was in the academy and he
came in and trained with us yeah
that's right yeah yeah he's into me all
the time about it how he just
absolutely boyed me i just wasn't really
expecting
you know how you some most guys you've
got gentleman agreements with especially
me
like i was not a massive and he's just
coming 100 and absolutely smoked me and
me
was watching from the sideline just
cracking up and i was like oh
i need to get out of this geez i
remember i remember going into the
changing room after that and just
getting
absolutely heckled by the boys like oh
snake he's got shooters out here trying
to take out the other thames
like he just wants game time he sent his
brother out here to fill jimmy in
oh did you have a part of it maybe he
did now that you mentioned no
no no no no because i did build up a bit
of a reputation there because of a few
unfortunate there was a few unfortunate
incidents in a row wasn't there i
kicked the ball and steal his face and
knocked him out oh that's right and then
i injured somebody else in a training
game because i fell on their knee
and then there was like three in a row
or something something like that and
then everyone started saying that i was
out
trying to uh injure people to get a game
anyway let's get back yeah yeah let's
get back let's get back
so um yeah i remember my old man
was a big fan had always uh always been
a big rugby fan and he
um i'm kind of part of that generation
in england where like
uh we won the world cup in 2003 and then
my old man would have taken me down to
my local club
in maybe 2004 i don't know that's right
on the money with the numbers but it was
about there sort of off the back of
johnny wilkinson and
you know the rugby world cup win and all
that yeah um
so i yeah went down to my local club
he played there was real average like
real skinny kid
like all my memories from that time were
just being cold
all the time like shivering not wanting
to be there
but i loved i loved rugby um we were
season ticket holders at london irish
my uh my old man used to uh
three three like work get a couple
tickets for the england game so every
now and then if
uh like uh one of his colleagues dropped
out or whatever i'd managed to sneak in
there to a six nations game or something
that absolutely loved it
um and then uh
went through school just went i went to
just a normal state secondary school
uh here in the uk but it just happened
by pure chance to
be a school that ended up having a
really good couple of years of rugby
teams uh
johnny williams was in the year above me
um obviously in the whale squad now
jack cook was in my year who's um in the
london irish squad with me now
and there was a couple other guys that
have gone on and become like real good
club players
um and then uh our rugby coach
at the school again like this is a
little state school that
is you know in the middle of nowhere um
our coach was a really good rugby coach
he's
uh actually one of the academy coaches
at london irish now oh yeah
and um so we we all kind of from
11 till 16 were playing uh rugby there
and we'd go around and play all the big
private schools and
we would end up pumping a lot of the
private schools um
i made a few county teams and rep teams
and stuff but i was never
i was never gone like just uh just love
the game
uh proper noise um love
working on my kicking and my passing and
all that kind of stuff so
um went through and then when you get to
16 and i i don't know much about your
system over there but in the uk you kind
of there's two pathways to get into a
premiership team you either
go to or get a scholarship at one of the
big private schools and go play first
15 rugby or
there are these programs called ace
programs do you remember hearing about
those when you were
over here yeah and basically the way
they work is their
programs each premiership team runs a
program where they're linked with a
college
and players
can go there do their a-levels or b-tech
qualifications
alongside training in a full-time
professional environment at the club's
training ground
so when i was 16
the year before me johnny had gone and
done the program and i'd seen
he was going real good and um his career
was really starting to take off so i
thought you know
what would i have to lose uh trial for
that
um and ended up moving to sunbury just
around the corner from
the the london ice training round uh
moved in with a family
uh so i lived in diggs um like a local
family like took me in i had like a
bedroom there
they were they were brilliant like
really became like my second family like
uh fed me real good like um yeah
really nice people so i lived with them
for two years um which
at 16 was a bit difficult i guess moving
away from home and
kind of um sort of being separated from
your support network a little bit
how far were you from your home um only
like an hour
yeah but when you can't drive when
you're 16 it's
quite quite far um and obviously like
not going home to mum every night is
you know it's it's different i did
something i'd never done before yeah
um and i think that actually
really helped me getting away from home
and away from
my comfort zone and stuff i kind of just
thought well i'm here like i might as
well throw myself
all in um so like properly threw myself
all into that program
um so you know i was training every day
in the program i was getting in
extra training with uh deku daniho was
the running the program at that time and
james lightfoot brown was the
the um the backs coach there so two
really good coaches who now
both work with our first team um i just
remember
spending my whole time um nause trying
to get them to do extra stuff for me
trying to you know ask you know why i
wasn't getting picked in
uh you know if i wasn't playing for the
academy team at the weekend or
or whatever and um yeah i went through
that just i think i
really improved quickly in that program
it is kind of one of those like
fast programs where it's full on your
training five days a week
you're playing a game against other
apprenticeship programs every week
and you do kind of either sink or swim
you either a lot of the guys actually
end up finding out they don't
like rugby and really turn their back on
it and sadly like
some of the guys never end up playing
club rugby or they just go to uni and
suck it all in
yeah or you get guys on the other end of
the spectrum that are just like this is
for me
i want to be a professional rugby player
and throw themselves fully into it and
it's
it's the best way to fast-track yourself
into that program i think
yeah so then from that program and
all the local private schools in the
area so i guess this is where it's
similar to
to your uh system over in new zealand
the the best players
from the ace program and the private
schools will get put into
the academy team and then that academy
team of
15 23 players they go out and play in
the academy premiership
and then the best players from that team
get signed onto senior academy contracts
which is when they start
their training with the first team yeah
so um
i was in the ace team like i didn't make
the academy team in my first year
towards the end of the season i started
getting on the bench a bit but like
really wasn't
really in the mix um and then in my
second year i made the academy team
and just happened to be in a stack team
like um
we we had an absolutely stacked team we
had um
it was cookie in the back row with isaac
uh rory brand at nine meet ten
uh joe cocking a sega and benny loader
on the wings
matty williams theo ollie hassell
collins
tom parton was like our backline a
combination of that stuff
and um we won the academy premiership
and
um seven of those boys got offered
contracts at like christmas
i didn't get offered one uh there's a
couple other guys that didn't get
offered one
um and i remember being pretty gutted
but i was getting told you know oh
you're in the shop window you know
you're working hard like
like i kind of always took it as like oh
you're not that good but like you work
really hard so
you're in the shop window because you
work really hard yeah um
and then i'd smash my ankle up real bad
um
i uh kind of got my nose through the
line on the
starter play like when to try and get my
hands free and just remember you know
those ones where you get one high one
low and you just your ankle gets folded
yeah
um so it was real bad like yeah
separated my foot
um broke my ankle um and i knew i was
going to be out for
for six months and i remember um
thinking like well it's christmas
i'm gonna be up for six months i've not
been offered a contract yet like
this is probably gonna be it for me like
i'm gonna go to university and have a
crack at playing club and trying to work
my way up to what i should be
here what's that what age were you here
so i would have been
17 or 18. oh yeah so it was
it was the december before i would have
met you before the summer you would have
signed
um and i remember just being like yeah
like this is this is done for me
um and then that night when i got home
from the hospital um
becky downer gave me a ring and was like
look mate like
i've gutted to see your season's over
don't like lose hope i'm i'm going to
push really hard here
for for you uh in
the academy coaches meetings and he's
i'm really going to have you back here
but
like in return i need you to smash this
rehab and go in and show
kendo and the the other guys in the
academy
the academy coaching team that like
you're going to be super professional
he's like you obviously can't play so
go in and show you are going to be super
professional so i was like
coming in before school doing gym doing
like multiple rehab sessions a day
um just doing anything like and you know
like the classic like going in like just
making sure kendo sees you when you're
walking in the gym and stuff like that
morning yeah
[Music]
um yeah i managed to get back a couple
weeks early
from from when i was expected and i
managed to get myself on the bench for
an a-league game which is
uh what would you call that over in new
zealand it's like um
reserve comp yeah it's a premiership
reserve comp
so it's young guys guys coming back from
an injury stuff like that managed to get
myself on the bench for that came on for
like five minutes
like touched the ball twice tried to
throw the triple knife
uh threw it into touch like i just
remember being like i've got myself back
for this game that i shouldn't have been
playing in like
maybe there's a chance maybe um
and then kendo pulled me in and was like
look mate
we've uh we've seen you obviously want
this bad like
we're going to give you this contract it
sucks it's absolute peanuts you come and
do pre-season with the first team
like uh in the scene academy you do
pretty soon with the first team
um we'll see what happens here you go i
remember just being like oh
this is my chance um and then just
like threw myself fully into that
preseason
uh did everything a million miles an
hour
um which ended up holding me back a
little bit because they were like
chill out you're way too stressed you
need to you play intent you need to be
you need to be calm and relaxed
please um but in that season i think by
by the end of that pre-season they
extended me onto a proper secure
contract and
um i was kind of underway into working
up towards the first team and
i've got a few games that season jimmy
marsh took me under his wing
taught me how to stay square
i ended up playing a couple games the
next season i played a few more games
and then
eventually i signed my first senior
contract uh
two seasons ago oh god but you've been
loaned out to a couple of um
championship sides too
as well haven't you to get a little bit
more game time how have they been
yeah for sure mate class i loved it um
like i'm one of those all players i like
it you just want to play
yeah like training's good and and you
you can try and challenge yourself and
make
make little competitions for yourself in
training but it's it's not the same and
i guess we're lucky in england that
we've got a sort of a clear structured
system where
if you're a premiership club and you're
not playing you can go get laid out to a
championship club
or a national one club if you're a bit
younger and
um go play club rugby so i played for
some teams that made
absolutely loved it like um i played for
a team called rams
uh they're in national one they're
trying to push themselves to get to the
championship now
in my first season i went there like the
most i've ever enjoyed playing rugby
mate proper club rugby
proper good lads proper good diesel
like they and they sent it every weekend
it's so hard i remember being like this
like i was first i played
when i was like 17 being this like
little lad at the back of the bus like
and like they're on a trip back from
cornwall or whatever because in that
south
england pool you play everyone so
imagine like the pirates away trip these
lads are sending it
like they're doing like every like butt
funnels and all that
just there in the back class
and then the next season i got loaned
out to a slightly better team and then
the season after that i got loaned up to
a slightly better team played for
play for bedford and london scottish and
um ended up playing a decent amount of
champ rugby
um it's really good it's a if you're not
fast track and you're not playing the
premiership when you're 19 it's uh
it's a really good way to learn your
trade and um
you end up meeting some class lads that
like you have such a good time with
while you're trying to also improve as a
player it's a it's a really good way to
develop i think
yeah so how does that work you still had
to train with london irish but then
you'd get loaned out
on what thursday night or something
it's tough it's tough a lot of it
depends on the schedule of the team
you're going to so if you're going to
uh let's say a national one team or some
of the championship teams they run a
proper club
rugby schedule so train tuesday nights
train thursday nights play saturday
so you do like your whole training week
with irish and then tuesday and thursday
nights go also do an evening training
session with those teams
and then front up for them on saturday
and then be back in a monday morning for
with irish some of the other teams like
bedford and london scottish their
full-time professional teams
so it'd be a case of like monday i'd be
in with irish tuesday and we're scottish
thursday and with scottish friday team
run play come back in on monday or irish
and then you'd
you do end up getting a little if it's
not well organized
you do end up being all over the place i
remember one day i was on
i was in the car driving to scottish
training at like 11am
and uh you're probably in the massage
room or whatever and
i remember getting a call from bv being
like where are you and i was like
uh bv i'm on london scottish like i'm
playing for them this weekend that's why
i'm there
and he was like get into hazelwood now
i've got no tens for training
and i was like oh but bv like this is a
tuesday we're preparing for a big game
like i'm starting
at the weekend for this club and he was
like no
get in now so i did a nice full
handbrake turn straight back to
hazelwood
come and train call the london scottish
coach apologize as to why
i couldn't be there to train for this
game i'm playing in at the weekend
so who did you play okay it can be like
that did you play for like
london irish no uh for london i know you
would have been playing i i it would be
wanted me in to train because he had no
sense of training
and i think it was train to run
northampton's plays
oh yeah like i think i think someone
might have been at 10 for irish
but he didn't have a 10 to run
northampton's plays and he was like
get here now
oh and your goal kicking is another
thing i wanted to talk about because
you're obviously like a guru goal
kickout
95 plus percent just obviously haven't
had
um the big stage to show um the world
that
how quality you are at goal kicking and
i know there's a lot of people
especially flying finn etc who
want to know a little bit more detail
about your kicking
routine so talk me about your goal king
routine how did you get so good
um thanks jim that's very common
um i think i cut my teeth around some of
the best in training mate all by the
kicking king tommy bell
that's a hell of a guy to learn under um
no i think
for me i've i've worked with some some
top kicking coaches and i've learned a
lot from them i've
been really lucky and had some
opportunities to work with some guys
like charlie hodgson for example
like just off the top of my head who's
you know i think he's either the top
premiership point scorer or he's second
or something
had an opportunity to work with him and
i think i took a lot out of those in
terms of improving my technique and
learning
more about my technique but actually i
think the best kicking coach i've ever
worked with is james either brown
because the way i always instantly go to
processing is to like massively
overthink them and overanalyze them
and end up trying too hard and whenever
i was kicking with him he used to always
just be like
mate boot the ball through the posts
like put that over in the rectangle like
it's not hard to bang it and he always
used to say to me like
if i was going to kick in session you
just walk over and just go stand and
bang stand and bang like just smack it
as hard as you can
i think because he knew that i was
putting in the work like the foundation
work to have
a good technique at a young age and and
he knew that i was thinking about all
these things he'd just come over to me
and be like
when you're practicing forget about that
like just dang it bang it and then
it kind of got me into a place where i
became really relaxed with kicking i
sort of saw it as just like
you're just kicking the ball through the
posts like
i think so many guys can get bogged down
and like where's my foot
where's my chest like you know i've seen
you believe it
i've seen you hit some good ones and uh
i have i have
no idea when you you know when you hit a
good one mate you never go into it
thinking like
all right plant foot tall chest shift my
weight through and then excel through
the person you are brilliant whenever
you do that you end up like
squirting out to the right like when you
when you go into it just like thinking
about nothing and you just smack it
it's clean um and that's when you hit
your best kicks i think
something i learned was maybe less is
more a bit sometimes
and actually spending three hours out
there practicing your technique
can actually make you worse whereas
doing 20 minutes
30 minutes regularly putting yourself
under lots of pressure
in terms of doing competitions against
other players i used to love kicking
comps
irish when you were there um we used to
go real good at those
you used to go real good real good
do you remember because
my hip was obviously real tired and i
used to just have to start hobbling off
the field as soon as i saw those
okay this was the thing man i don't
because you
didn't moan and you wouldn't make a big
deal about it i don't think most of the
boys knew this
because i remember finding out your hip
was [ __ ] and
being like what because you're not
you're not the kind of guy that would
like moan and be like oh geez my head is
sore today
i can't do the textures you just kind of
like quietly sneak off
i don't actually think that anybody knew
that you had a shag tip
oh that's good i guess well it's not
maybe we need to tell them
that's why i wasn't doing those three
hour extras with you yeah
i used to be out on that field for a
long time though and it's interesting
hearing you talk about
um that might have been too much because
i always thought that
because you were out there for so long
that was probably why you were
such a successful kick about it's
interesting to hear you say that
potentially less is more
i i do believe that there's a there's a
balance i think
also like similar to you there was a
point sort of
um towards the end of my second year
where i like shagged up my hip i and my
um i had osteoarthritis pubis did i
speak to you about it
do you like i think quite a few of the
guys in the southern hemisphere get it
it's something that happens quite often
when the pictures are really hard yeah
but it's one of the worst things i've
ever had it basically every time you go
to run every time you get a sprinting
kick
feels like somebody's stabbing you like
in the bottom of your abs
and it's real bad like you can get like
real sharp pains in your balls and stuff
as well like it's a real niggle injury
and i started getting that and thinking
like maybe i'm
maybe i'm doing too much here like this
is not good because
like i can't get picked if i'm not fit
and all i want to do is get picked so
what am i doing
um i do like i said earlier i do think
that like
if you're out there for two hours three
hours you're probably wasting most your
time nobody can be focused for three
hours
yeah i think your best thing is to do
half an hour tops
but super super focused yeah and putting
yourself under pressure and trying to
challenge yourself to get better
rather than just going through the
motions for three hours jeez it's good
advice from the kicking king
well number two kicking king behind tell
me about i i've got my advice from the
kicking king i'm just passing it off
well one thing that happens at london
irish is the old paddle so you have to
run the gauntlet if you
after your first game you have to sing a
song if you've listened to
mike koeman's podcast he famously got
paddled trying to sing
kelly ignition he just kept going again
and again she forgot the word
so talk to me about your pedal
experience you would have got pedaled
for sure
no matter how good yourself oh mate i i
think i just literally stepped up the
front picked up the microphone and just
heard nas at the back like
um i can't remember i actually can't
remember what song i did
i remember going i remember going up
after tom parton
who'd just done a real sketchy version
of take that shine and hadn't got
paddled
so i was like oh this is golden like i'm
a better singer than him i've got song
choices in him
i'll be fine we're not there i swear to
god i sung like one verse
and then boys are like smashing the
chairs like there's people flopping at
the mouth
like oh yeah took my shirt off ran down
caught some serious slaps i think becky
danaher actually caught me the worst i
think he hit me with a shoe
um run up i missed the back of the bus
i went to touch the back of the bus and
somebody's caught me right between the
shoulder blades and i fell
and then i was like i've got to the back
of the bus i'll turn around turn around
started running back towards the front
and then somebody's just got stepped in
the alleyway who would have been
probably nas has gone you didn't touch
the back go back and this whole time i'm
just getting belted built and
like run back touch the back of the bus
get back to the front of the bus again
so i end up doing nearly four lengths
my back is like probably bleeding this
battered little like
70 kilo skinny kid after my first game i
think i'm like jeez
when does it get good
it's good
honestly like when it's not you it's
brilliant it's the funniest thing in the
world when it's not you yeah
a lot of it's who you are not what
you're saying but i was yeah they were
always ready to fill me in yeah
yeah you could have you could have done
a sam smith
spectacular version of one of the live
acoustics and you still would have got
the pedal
100 100 uh well geez that was a good
story but uh
socials another good part of london
irish that i remember over there there's
plenty of good socials because in new
zealand you obviously have your
end of season dues the seasons are a lot
shorter sort of just builds up to
um a big end of season some have a
mid-season
thing but i'm london irish you've got
heaps of socials throughout the year to
keep the boys entertained and keep a
good bond over everyone
any good social experiences or memories
from you
oh we had some great ones and we we we
were really lucky we had
some really good social sex and social
teams that organized those things i
remember
my first couple years it was was it
gilly and
they organized some some good stuff uh
and then stealing said to go for a
little bit and it was like it was loose
but it was nowhere near as organized
nowhere near as smooth uh
and then the last couple years mattie
williams pat silly has to go for a bit
but yeah it's been mainly matty williams
uh he's been running it recently and
maybe he goes good organizing the good
social
um but actually the first time i would
have probably become
powers with you would have been on uh
would have been on the christmas social
oh yeah the legendary christmas social
so
um geez gilly and louie were good at
organizing these
we basically got split the whole squad
into four teams
yeah and there was like a real good
variety in each team like mixer ages
uh mixer positions and stuff maybe guys
you wouldn't normally hang out with
and each team got told to start at a
certain location which was pubs
basically died across
south west london so i remember rocked
up to
that we were in uh no we're at orange
street weren't we in richmond oh you're
testing my memory now
but yeah but we're all in we're all in
christmas fancy dress
um so we turned up there and then behind
there the barman or something had an
envelope of the next place we had to go
to and then it was like a trail you had
to
all follow and and all the teams were
following different trails that
eventually met up but went to wonderland
at the end
um and again that would have been the
first time i would have gone out with
most of the lads and
mate we had a loose team yeah we had
steely
will lloyd you gotta get him on geez
he's got some stories
um you george robson uh
who else do we have ramo he's not great
value but he's loose
um kimbo
we have kimbo as well yeah kibbo you've
got a
memory that was
that was gone we went really well for
that and i remember towards the end of
that social
it ended up in one of the weirdest
situations of my life
i was like 18. bear in mind i've been
like a london irish fan my whole life i
was like 18
at london i've seen and i ended up in a
pub with three other people
in the middle of nowhere in kingston you
mike coleman and david pace oh and five
people there and said
as well and i'm
or something everybody start breaking up
into their own little groups to go
sort of find their way home via various
alcohol establishments in london
um so we ended up at this one and i
remember you just be like i'll say come
with me we're going to the bricklayers
i'm going to find move because i think
you'd been tasked with getting move home
or something oh yeah probably
so we got back to kingston spent ages on
google maps trying to find this pub
like eventually we found it i think we
stopped at an off license on the way and
got a few cans of like
whatever disgusting thing they had to
like keep us going but i got to this pub
and the pile was pretty empty it was
pretty [ __ ] pub i remember thinking
um and walk in and mike coming at david
pace
are battered playing darts in the corner
so we walked over like stopped playing
darts with the boys going right
you kept getting brought these drinks
and like like complaints and then there
was like some shots or something came
around
and i remember thinking like when no
one's paid for these like and there's
nobody in this pub
like what's the cracking we're going for
ages now
we played played darts at ages like i
was i was
steaming but mike and pacey were
cut like they were absolutely out of it
and
uh i remember like a like someone comes
like this man comes over to pacey and
it's like
oh look dave i'm gonna lock up now
you've got to go home like
keto you make it out it's obviously the
landlord
so pacey's gone like oh don't worry boys
i've got a nice bottle of whiskey back
at my place like uh we'll go over there
something to go
okay get weird i'm gonna end up at
pacey's house i don't really know him
he's like he's like he's like a 34 year
old battler at the time i'm like 18.
that's my first night out with the last
so we walk out the front of the pub and
i'm thinking like
we're going to get uber or something
like how are we gonna get the paces
he literally walks straight across the
road
straight into the the house opposite the
pub starts trying to put his key in the
door
so like all right start a piece together
this is obviously pacey's local that
we've ended up in and we've gone
straight back to his house
opens up the front door like all the
lights are off and stuff going to the
kitchen
and i remember he said something like oh
that's keep it down like i've got a
young baby or whatever like yeah
yeah he just had a kid on me and then he
goes top shelf
in the kitchen pulls down a bottle of
whiskey goes to pass it to moon
but like puts the bottle out in front of
me moo does nothing with his hands
and just lets the bottle go and it
smashes straight on the kitchen floor
there's this loud smash i think we're
still in the dark as well at this point
smashes all over the floor and then
there's this awkward silence where
everyone's like
and then like slowly everyone kind of
starts to relax a bit like pacey starts
laughing
like all the boys like this is funny and
i remember the kitchen door opening
and just this woman coming in just going
david pace what the
[ __ ] are you doing you've got a [ __ ]
three-month-old kid asleep in the next
room and you bringing these
[ __ ] idiots throughout my [ __ ]
house get the [ __ ] out of here
i remember us bolting out the door and
you just screamed like
good luck pacey and then and then yeah
we were out of there we got an uber back
to uh
we've got an uber back to mike coleman's
teddington residence
oh geez one place
carried him carried carried moving to
the door back there and that's when i've
got all those videos of uh
all the boys trying to undress me and
get him into bed
look after him get him in safely
yeah what a do what a social
oh there were some good ones mate there
were some good ones and what about your
um date with
big philo paulo
fizzy p um oh yeah that was another good
one
so we were in we're
we had a hard block of pre-season hadn't
we was like first block of pre-season
and uh they'd organized like a long
weekend trip for us to bournemouth which
if you're not from the uk bournemouth is
kind of like
kind of like a nothing seaside town kind
of thing
sort of like no one really i don't
really know where it is it's
yeah so we they carted the whole team
off and all
support staff and everyone for this like
three-day thing in bournemouth
um and like the first day we did like
all the generic stuff didn't we like
[ __ ] um like did we get out on the
water did we
go on pedalboarding and stuff i think if
we had paddle boarding or jet ski
it's like something like that the first
day it was freezing cold and everyone
was hating it yeah
but the second day they'd organized um
this thing where you had to go around
bournemouth
in teams and there was like challenges
you had to get done
so the challenges were like take a
picture here
down a pint here get uh eat the fastest
pancake at this restaurant
that we had to get to and like all the
the venues we were going to like knew
what was going on
um and we're all in the different teams
and you'd get points for completely
different things and there was supposed
to be a
a team that would win at the end and um
you had to take video evidence of it all
to
say we're going to put a video back
together when we got back to the club
yeah so we went
we went through ours and uh we were
going good we had we had a good team
matthew williams you blair uh a couple
other lads
but but fizzy p and one of our last
things that we'd left
on our list of things to do was get a
day on the bournemouth eye which is like
a really naff
version of the london eye like uh one of
those spin around things
we like left it towards at the end and
this is like we've been going since like
10 a.m so everyone's pretty fed up
how are we gonna do this like i think
we've gone and approached a few birds
maybe and been like oh
will you go on a date with one of us at
the bournemouth high and they were like
get like get out of here like you losers
um so i think at one point jimmy was
like you you were like
we could always dress snake up as a bird
and i was like what
and blair i remember blair being like
[ __ ] that's a good idea
so then i got again i'm this is still in
my first season so
i'm very much down the bottom of the
pecking order i don't have much say in
we went up to this charity shop like got
this like horrible skimpy dress
someone else went to a fancy dress shop
and got a wig high heels like
the boys dressed me up as a girl
and then fizzy p who's like six foot six
six at seven
absolutely massive we made this video of
me going on a date with him
on the bournemouth eye and in the video
you can see people in the background
like the beach was packed on that day it
was like a saturday afternoon summer
and you can just see people like turning
their heads watching us like oh geez
we're going on this wheel we took a few
selfies on the thing
for the competition and um all the boys
were cracking up it was real good i
remember on the way down as i was
getting
out of the bombify i saw a kid like a
five-year-old kid and his mum and the
kid was wearing a london irish hoodie
i just remember thinking oh geez he's
like please
you pulled it off pretty well you had
it was good i was good i was good but
but then it kind of became a bit of a
thing and then
there was a couple other socials where i
went dressed as a woman because it kind
of become a thing like oh it's social
it's fancy dress like snake i'm dressed
as a bird
i did a for a party i did a real good we
did a game of thrones one i went as
uh daenerys with ben loder he went as
carl drogo did you see the picture of
that yeah
um but yeah geez that was one of those
situations that you get there's a
younger player in the squad where you're
like i can't say no
because well i don't have to say
how was it going around the um what is
it the ferris wheel thing
i just remember being real scared
because i actually didn't really know if
uh feeling that well
at the time like i again i didn't really
know that well he'd only been there for
a couple months and
i was obviously not very serious yeah i
remember just thinking
that's a bit awkward so um
who did you play for before you signed
here like just sat there like oh cool
you brought family over yet oh nice it
was a bit like that
my man dressed as this bird with like my
ass hanging out the back of this dress
oh classic oh some of the greats anymore
any more social stories you got for the
waddle and listeners oh
no more that aren't that aren't touch
and go i'd be dropping a few boys in
there i'd have to get permission for
some of the stories yeah
no not i can think of the top of my head
there might be a few more that come
through on the questions a few guys have
asked some good questions but
before we get to that what's what's next
for big
big jacob atkins what's what's your
plans how how long have you signed with
london irish and
um how long are you so i am just just
come out to the end of
a two-year contract actually i'm out of
contract at the end of the season
so normally by christmas like as you'd
know normally by christmas most
recruitment stuff would be getting
wrapped up
uh all the boys would know what their
plans are for next year and stuff but
because of kodavid and
like i said we're only like six seven
eight weeks into the season
that's all back quite a bit in the uk so
we're kind of
it's almost at the start of the season
yeah um so i don't really know
uh at the moment um i'd like to stay
irish i um
i really like it there i um it's like i
said it's obviously a team i've
supported since i was since i was young
but also i've got a really good group of
friends there that i've come through
the academy playing with i like all the
staff i i like coming into work every
day and
working with those people so i'd like to
stay there but yeah
i'm out of contract at the end of the
year so um hopefully you get some game
time and then
we'll see what happens would you would
you look to go overseas
um depends what if you were running the
team maybe
are you gonna offer me a contract here
live on the pod exclusive
free rent at mike coman's house down the
road
oh geez that would be a good gigantic oh
that's another good stay with mike
play some tuzzie is it true you once
told um kendo that you had a threesome
with mike and his wife didn't you
[Laughter]
this is actually this is actually
another a good yarn from another social
um so this
for anyone who listens to the pod that
doesn't know jimmy what he does is he
he does this thing where he like lose
you into a false sense of security by
setting you up to say something stupid
and then we'll use it against you for
the rest of your life
so i remember like again being maybe
even on that first social when we would
move being sat there like
um no it was we'd gone to moose the
story i was telling earlier when we'd
end up back at moves the next time we
went out
you were like oh you saw lazar uh
musa moves places are they like uh what
do you think
moose punching pretty pretty good isn't
it isn't he like her she's she's pretty
harmless
yeah yeah she's she looks nice yeah yeah
for sure for sure
and then i remember like mood coming in
like one day to be like snake i've heard
you
have you been trying to go for my wife
and i was like what
he was like yes some boy's been saying
that
you've got a thing for my wife or
something
and at that point i was like oh like you
set me up a treat
welcome so essentially all i've done was
reply yes to a question
but this has now become a thing i
remember after we won the championship
we had
we had a lock-in at hazelwood
which is the training ground we had a
lock-in and it was like real good like
um
we had the game there was an evil game
and then we gone straight back
to the training ground and uh i remember
you i was going to get a round of drinks
or something and you were like oh
um was ollie had just been born maybe
and you're like can i borrow your phone
to call uh my wife to make sure that
everything's all good with the baby and
just so i can relax and have a good
night or whatever
so like oh knock yourself out like
here's my phone i'll go get us the
drinks
i think we probably sat with me at the
time i came back to my phone and you're
in
stitches like cracking up i'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] why have i done this gone on
my phone
scrolled through gone on my instagram
messages and jimmy has sent
mike's wife a message on my account
i might have to read it i'll try to find
it now sent this message
and how should i think
hey lord jacob atkins here academy star
player at london irish
i love you and always have since the
first social last year
i know this might sound a bit crazy but
if you're ever keen to cheat on mike
then i'm your man
oh and yeah
and then so that same night i went into
the bathroom
for a piss and i'm still at the urinal
and kendo the club dor the big boss
stands next to me at the urinal and just
kind of goes
snake i heard you trying to [ __ ] moe's
wife
oh how is this this happened 20 minutes
ago kendo how has this spread already
oh jeez jeez what did she reply back
she replied back laughing faces i'll be
sure to let you know
oh geez she's good oh that's classic so
maybe you won't be staying with me
if you do come here it might be a bit
awkward
but would you would you um seriously
come to new zealand for a um
contract would you so i've spoken to
soph
my sophie my girlfriend about um would
we ever potentially look at going
overseas
and she's real keen for it we i think
something we both love the opportunity
to do is live in japan
for even if it was just for a short
period of time that's obviously
something
you've done um it just it would be cool
to experience something really different
yeah um new zealand i've actually never
been
to new zealand or australia i'd love to
i'd love to come over
i don't know yeah i don't know i don't
know i'm real open-minded
and i love rugby so i'll go anywhere
[Laughter]
how good anyway let's get to some of
these questions
because i know popular man like yourself
you've had a few a few good ones come
through
okay first question are you able to
bench press more than your body weight
yet
yes what's your bench press
um is this is this bit of a writing joke
were you always
poor at bench press so i was always
real skinny i always used to make a lot
of excuses myself in the gym as well
like i really struggled with like
not injuries but it was sort of like
like long-term niggles
like i'd always had dodgy knees and a
bit of a dodgy back or
whatever and i'd always kind of been
like oh that's why i'm not going so hard
in the gym
and then last last year irish we had a
new snc coach rock up
a guy from glasgow you know he's called
derek and he was just like
fully just like going to me like mate i
don't care
like get this up like you're stronger
than you think you are get this up
eat more and he just takes me through
the day like eat now eat now
come in live now it's your day off come
in and live um
so i actually made some real good
progress recently i've got 140 up
for one yeah i've got 140 up for one i
think my
breasts probably i've got 135 for
three i think maybe it's my best so yeah
i can bench but i don't weigh 136.
so i can i can bench my bodyweight
almost double what imagine
okay next question why do they call you
snaker
right this is a story
here we go that has since you left
taken had a mind of its own mate it's
gone
there's so many false stories out there
i've had fans come
to me and try to tell me why i'm called
snake and i'm like that is
what um actually i had this conversation
with soph
was she was like uh you reckon jimmy ask
you about the
um why they call you snake and she was
like oh yeah it's because of this isn't
it and i was like
no and she was like oh matty williams
told me that's what it was and i was
like
no it's not there's some elaborate
stories as to why i'm called snake
here's your
chance like like all great nicknames
that stick
the actual story is real [ __ ]
it's not exciting at all so i remember
walking into the analysis room
at london irish all the laptops were
taken up
so i stood in the doorway for a few
seconds and ross neal got up
and when i'm going to get my notepad out
of the changing rooms
do not go on this computer i'm still
using it so he walked out
and i went straight to the laptop logged
him out and started getting watching my
own stuff
he walked in the door and like ross is
like real dramatic
he walked back in the door and just went
oh
classic snake up and just walked off
and i remember you yours your your
little head in the corner perked up with
your
black snap back on like remember
i've gone away on my thing and i think
couple of boys left it was only me and
you in the analysis room
and this might have been the first
conversation we had actually ever
and you've just gone why do the boys
call you snake
they don't it's just ross was annoyed at
me and branched my name like he's
they don't you go oh they will now
and then this is where you're gonna have
to take over did you then go
and tell kibbo to get in on it because
for the next month
every time i did anything at the club
like i'd catch a ball
i'd do acceleration in the warm-up just
you and kimbo just
yes snag oh snakey how good
oh like non-stop free trainer non-stop
and then i remember like maybe a couple
of months later i got names in the team
for my first
start and clark clark is going through
the team
and he's like sneaky you'll be in at ten
and i was like
yeah and then for two years nobody
called me jacob in london irish
not one person snake if it is um
yeah it's nice a little bit it started a
little bit in recent years i thought it
was um i thought you've
named it way before that well because
you heard ross say it i think you
obviously assumed that it was a thing
but
no you and kibbo started it oh what a
nickname
what a story okay next question from bin
laden
top three bald icons
jesus what a great question top three i
think i know one
top three ball icons
who do you think is
i'll see if you can yeah um
in in rugby or in the world in the world
any anywhere okay okay okay top three
ball icons top three ball icons
um jason statham okay
rocks it makes it look cool
jason statham
nathan lyons oh yeah australian cricket
bowler bowling gaza
yeah icon um
johnny sins oh wonder
and um
last one like the rock maybe
because if you're gonna be if you're
gonna be bald you've gotta try and get
swole
you know what i mean geez i'd be a hell
of a crew
oh i can't believe being frank's missed
here
he would have definitely been in my
rugby ball icons 100 well let's go your
rugby ball
oh i can't all time
are we saying full ball like brave to
shave or like can i count guys that are
real receders
nah brave to shave like you ready to
shave right
ben franks yeah straight off the bat
um
felipe conte pony okay nice
ten ten yeah there you go um
yeah and oh i got billy meeks
makes it look real good good player good
lad
yeah billy meeks a couple of good top
threes there snape
hey thanks boss okay next question is
lazarus the goat
this is the goat well
he's better than your old pony what was
that the director jesus
that thing used to go like a wheelie
boss
lazarus the greatest racehorse of all
time come on lazarus is the greatest
trotter of all time i've done about
racehorse there's a few big ones over
here you've got like red ramen
and all those guys but in carriage
racing he is
the goat never be better
want me a lot of money at that point
oh there's a lot of time okay
this one's from luke mclean what's the
secret from going from a full head of
hair to completely bored and under two
years um
being a battler and a premiership team
that is stressful
i'll take anyone's hair off um lee
mclean that's a great head of
hair isn't it imagine if the secret is
um um i always had a bad hairline so i
think he's he's being very generous to
me there to say from a full head of hair
to hold it in two years i think i never
started with a full head of hair you're
born with a receder
yeah straight up lasagna out of the wood
but i think they say they say stress
don't they like can can accelerate going
boards
maybe maybe i'm quite stressed quite
high functioning
yeah make sure you talk to someone
um has paddy jackson now replaced jimmy
marshall as your favorite number 10. oh
asking me tough questions here jim this
is from luke as well
paddy jackson is a very good lad
a very good player um
has he replaced jimmy mike he's not as
square as you though boss
he likes it i've heard him he said to me
before like oh i can just
i think i can just kick out to the
second defender here and then affect the
line and i've just gone
oops don't do that stay square
like i'm in my head i'm looking at and
i'm like it makes sense like
yeah if you could get out one more
defender like it makes sense but then in
the back of my head i'm like jimmy he's
just like
say square man like don't get back on
what you believe so
for pure square purposes jim i have to
say you the squares bloke ever evans
playing the premiership
square and straight okay
do you still think about missing that
run out at headingley
so that was the best summer of my life
man jesus christ
this is a joke about me being nathan
lyon so when
um the summer that summer of cricket in
england when we won the world cup and it
went straight back into an ashes series
like
i'm a huge cricket fan like a massive
cricket fan i've always loved it
but loads of the boys i managed to get
loads of boys into it over the world cup
and then in the ashes
so everyone was into it by the time that
happened
and uh the australian team when nathan
lyons bowles are like i don't know if
you if you've watched much of it but
like every time he bowls you just hear
them in the band like bowling gaza
oh yes gary lovely nathan like the whole
time
so boy started doing that to me in
training and actually it took away from
the snake a little bit there's some boys
at the club that only call me gary now
gary yeah curtis rona every morning just
gary oh yeah um
but genuinely watching that watching him
miss that run out and then stoke see
when stokes had crashed that one through
the covers to win i cried
i was so happy watching nathan line
missed the run out
that whole day oh i'm tearing up
thinking about it
that was unbelievable let's get to the
new zealand
england cricket world cup final that
would have to be the greatest game of
all time
again i cried yeah when we won um
that was the probably
in terms of i think i enjoyed the
headingley test more
because it's australia it's the ashes
and like i'm
die hard test cricket and i guess you
didn't actually win that um one
that other game did you because it was
technically you went off down
that's what everyone on social media is
saying but in terms of
actual quality of the game that was the
best game of any sport i've ever seen
yeah the england new zealand like back
and forth all day long i i
did not miss a ball like sam watched the
whole thing um
dude that was so good i mean you guys
must be gutted
like they deserve to win that so bad and
also like if it was like india or
australia like i'd be like
yeah like oh you lose because they're
all terrible blokes but the new zealand
team are all
such good lads and they seemed so they
seemed so nice like
watching kane williamson after the final
just going around smiling congratulating
all the england players like
i just felt so bad for them they
deserved
they deserved it there number one test
team in the world though they are easy
do you think
ah there's some good test cricket teams
man there's some good test cricket teams
it'd be interesting to see obviously
india just did the job on australia the
death of australian cricket
so be good to see england india then we
go against you boys then we go against
uh australia in the winter so i think by
the end of the year we'll know
oh [ __ ] you love your christmas jesus
you should get some of them on the water
lad podcast if you can who would you
want
uh in that team oh like the
kane williamson and ross taylor and that
would be cool but i think uh ferguson
would go you know with the guy with a
big mustache i think i feel like
you feel like he's like diesel stories
yeah he seems like a lad
oh good stuff okay next question is
featuring on this podcast the greatest
accomplishment of your career so far
this is from blair gallery
yes it's top two uh number one is still
um being sat next to blair coming in the
locker room yeah
achievement of my career sit next to him
yeah do you yeah
he puts his kit in my locker every
single day and tells me to leave the
club
and then when i move his stuff out my
locker he stares me down and asks what
i'm doing
he's taken my name tag off my locker and
moved it outside the changing room
he's wrapped all my kit up in cling film
and thrown it in the swimming pool
[Laughter]
he said to me he's like if you put your
bag in front of my locker one more time
i'm throwing it from the ball and like
generally the next day by pure accent
i'd sat in my locker but put my bag next
to his and gone up to go to a meeting
yeah
i came back my bag was wrapped in
physiotape
floating in the swimming pool
so that's still the highlight of my
career yeah fair enough
okay uh does the snake have any relation
to nathan lyon here we go
i've actually i actually tried uh
message him on him on instagram
um we were during lockdown the
the boys were all getting pretty good
and we were all you know i hadn't seen
each other for months
so one of the boys had signed a thing
where uh you just uh once a week you
have a drink you're down
you scully beer or whatever and you go
oh cheers lads like i want to see this
guy down drink
one of the boy uh dolly tom partner down
to beer and was like
i want to see gary the goat chop a beer
bruh so i was then like
can i get nathan to chop a bit send me a
video and put it into the chat and ask
him to nominate one of the boys
so i started working my way around like
oh god how can i do this how can i get
this done
and benny meehan is school mates with
marnis lava shane who's in the australia
team
and i was pesting benny like benny benny
benny give me miles his number like send
him a text please
i need him to give me nathan lyons
number so i can get this video please
please um and uh benny was having none
of it it was like
no i can't like that's it they're not
gonna like that that's weird
i was like really funny please
um i left a message on instagram he's
not seeing it but it was along the lines
of like
gaza how you going you know take care um
just a quick one you've been nominated
to down a beer like uh boys would love
to hear from you
uh nominate one of the boys when you've
done it like thanks uh look forward to
hearing from you soon
it's not related it's
[Laughter]
oh i love that okay okay
couple more um favorite bloke from a
a s um
probably i'd have to say from my ace
team would be jack cook
cookie yeah you obviously played with
cookie you know you know he's a legend
uh absolute weapon on the piss lethal
um so yeah i'd say cookie best lad nice
okay
and then the best ace moment
best ace moment from that program
we so we had a bit of a rivalry with the
bristol team
uh uh which were felt in college and we
used to go real hard against each other
uh every year and they beaten us not sat
in the semi-final in my first year
and then the semi-final in my second
year we had them at home and we
absolutely banged them put like 45
uh 45 points unanswered on them
it was class yeah we got the uh yeah we
got we got we lost in the next round but
that was the playing highlight of my
career for sure what a moment
what a career it was magical it was
magical it's not it's not been better
since
oh what a journey snake and what a
career obviously um
like i said at the start not too many
kiwis would know you
but um hopefully after this episode they
know what a lad you are and can follow
your journey over at
london irish as you start getting a bit
more game time and
start breaking into the world scene and
the rugby circles because obviously
you're a quality player and i'm looking
forward to
um getting seeing you get your crack um
hopefully sometime soon but
really appreciate you coming on the
podcast and giving up your time mate
thanks tony give me a call about that
contract you were going to offer me
later though just let's do it
tasman team okay
thanks jim sweet mate thanks bro